the fastest way to accomplish any goal
is to model success find someone who's
already accomplished what you're trying
to do and put their strategies to work
for you so you don't have going down the
long road of failure frustration and
losing all your money in my first
business and seemed to take forever to
get things that go was a lot harder than
we thought it was going to be it was a
lot took a lot longer than we thought it
was going to take I was pulling out
three hundred dollars a month for months
three hundred dollars a month is not
enough to survive I had to say no to my
friends to go out to dinner did their
birthday parties because I couldn't
afford it and I was too embarrassed to
tell them hey guys I know you're making
eighty thousand dollars a year as an
investment banker and I'm supposed to be
live in the entrepreneur dream run in my
own business but I can't afford the
twenty bucks that is going to take to go
out and meet you guys for dinner or
drinks and there's a point where you hit
bottom where you get so frustrated that
you think I either have to find another
way to make this happen or I need to go
and do something else and for me the
light bulb went off when I realized you
know what I'm in the software business
I'm not the first guy to try to sell
software before someone has figured this
out I need to model their strategies and
make it work for me and so looked at
companies like Microsoft and how they
got started and within a month to doing
that I landed my first deal I brought in
thirteen thousand dollars from a new
company and I not only had the money
thirteen thousand dollars was awesome
you know maybe that's not a lot for you
right now but for me pulling out three
hundred bucks a month thirteen thousand
dollars was a lifeline but it wasn't
just the money I had a system now where
I could do it again and again and again
and my business took off and so whatever
problem you're facing right now someone
has solved it the answer is there you
don't want to come up with all the
answers yourself go out find it model
their success put it to work for you and
your business will transform I guarantee
it good luck